allo depuis l'homme à terre cette
famille est dans le désarroi
depuis deux jours il n'y a pas une
goutte d'eau du moins aujourd'hui n'est
franchement le rouge il s'est passé avec
le côté que 19 mois maintenant on nous
dit tout le temps il faudrait arrêter de
fumer mais là je me dis franchement on
ne sait plus quoi faire et c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui
deux grosses difficultés avec une maman
sous oxygène et nécessitant des soins
infirmiers quotidien alors le réflexe
dans l'incertitude du lendemain est de
faire des réserves de grandes quantités
d'eau en bouteille de l'eau dans les
faits tout une pénurie d'eau qui oblige
la mairie du lamentin à prendre des
mesures
ce midi pour des besoins domestiques ces
pompiers ont été appelés pour remplir
plusieurs citernes de trois mètres cubes
d'eau un soulagement pour le quartier
mikado traduit dans l'eau quelques en
pleine crise sanitaire et parce que
beaucoup de personnes sont confinées
cette sécheresse est un casse-tête
certes pour les usagers mais aussi pour
les opérateurs d'eau une sécheresse tout
aussi exceptionnel jamais le niveau ont
été aussi bas le carême de 2019 a été le
troisième plus gros carême constatée
depuis l'enregistrement des données
météo et ce car m6 de 2020 est
aujourd'hui en avance de trois mois sur
les déficits que nous avions constaté
par rapport à 2019 donc soit on se
dirige vers le carême le plus
déficitaire que l'on ait connu depuis
1948 selon les opérateurs des stratégies
ont été mises en place des coupures dans
la distribution de l'eau par quartier
ont été instaurées ou encore limitée
l'alimentation des réservoirs
l'idée elle est très simple si nos
abonnés jouent le jeu de
de prélever un minimum pour uniquement
les besoins domestiques
nous serons mesure de jd beaucoup moins
les réservoirs et donc de pouvoir
assurer une distribution la plus longue
possible pendant ces tours d'eau au
niveau des zones impactées
alors comment faire des gestes simples
pratiques et citoyens peuvent limiter la
consommation malgré les contraintes
sanitaires
il se résume à quelques petites choses
quand je fais la vaisselle je laisse pas
couler l'eau j'ai deux bassines une
machine pour effectivement savonner ma
vaisselle et une bassine pour un ses
premiers gestes simples deuxième ch est
simple je suis avec les enfants qui
utilisent l'eau pour se brosser les
dents
j'utilise le simplement pour mouiller ma
brosse à dents je ferme le robinet et je
me reste avec une petite timbale d'eau
nous avons un cap difficile à passer ce
cap va durer de l'ordre de 7 à 10 jours
car le risque menace un risque de
coupure drastique les prochaines puis
n'arriveront pas avant une dizaine de
jours
responsabilisation de tous est le maître
mot